[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce matin d'ailleurs il y avait des
bombes au phosphore des bombes le russe
au phosphore les adultes ont encore été
tués le phosphore est utilisé dans deux
raisons c'est pas vraiment une arme
chimique interdite soit pour faire des
fumigènes donc ça fait un des fumées et
ça permet de de masquer des objectifs
soit pour éclairer les russes ne peut
pas utiliser ce genre de bombes qui sont
interdit par les conventions
internationales
fès est absolument possible et c'est pas
notre méthode de faire penser à cette
étude la majorer plutôt tendance à dire
c'est avait un effet éclairant et donc
ce n'est pas une arme non
conventionnelles non ça n'est pas une
arme non conventionnelles face à cette
guerre en ukraine 3 sommets sont prévues
à bruxelles aujourd'hui sommet de l'otan
le g7 ainsi qu'un conseil européen en
présence du président américain joe
biden
je ne marche pas dans cette caricature
l'acquis qui quoi qui présente en gros
le camp occidental comme comme les
bienfaiteurs les bienfaiteurs de
l'humanité mais ou dites moi où très
clairement livrer de nouveaux
équipements
en particulier avions hochart
aujourd'hui personne ne la franchit
parce que il est évident qu'elle
caractériserait une comédie gérance ce
ne sont pas nos usines renault nos
magasins leroy merlin voilà ça c'est
quand même il façon de présenter les
choses complètement
incroyable parce que non ils
appartiennent à des actionnaires privés
à des grandes familles bourgeoises si on
avait considéré de dire que dire à
toutes nos entreprises partent et de la
russie ça servait cet objectif on
l'aurait fait nos clients rappaz il y
aura pas de message en son sens il ya le
sommet européen yanis ne va pas dire à
toutes les entreprises européennes de
quitter la russie il ya des sanctions
qui ont déjà été décidées notamment le
fait pas avoir d' investissement
supplémentaire total veut me faire taire
total veut me faire taire en pleine
campagne électorale présidentielle mais
vous savez moi ça fait 30 ans que chez
de l'écologie ça fait trente ans que je
mène ce combat là on a toujours eu les
menaces des lobbys des sanctions qui
pourraient venir en réalité à se mettre
une balle dans le pied à ceux
sanctionnés soi même et surtout à
pousser la russie dans les bras de la
chine qui ne viendrait que renforcer
l'autonomie stratégique de la russie est
donc à la rendre en vérité encore
puissance j'ai été espionnée par odf et
maintenant j'ai j'ai eu une attaque
juridique de total c'est l'hommage
politique qui a fait polémique avec des
drapeaux français et européen et corse
mis en berne sur la façade de la
préfecture
un bâtiment d'état un geste qui a choqué
jusqu'au président de la république
c'est une faute et c'est inapproprié je
peux entendre qu'il ya une émotion chez
ses proches bien évidemment mais encore
une fois je pense que c'était un geste
de la part de la collectivité de corse
qui était inapproprié oui ça me choque
parce que parce que il y a un grand
préfet de la république qui a été
assassiné il y a eu un procès ce procès
a décidé de qui était coupable j'ai dit
mon désaccord profond au président
simeoni je lui dit oralement je lui ai
exprimé effectivement cela vous l'avais
appelé spécial branger des relations de
confiance avec lui le gouvernement a
tremblé il tremble encore un peu il
s'inquiète même des conséquences puisque
la dette de deutsch est logique mais
dans quelques jours le gouvernement et
doit se poser les questions sur comment
ça va évoluer monsieur colonna pour qui
j'ai un peu plus le respect pour son
deuil de sa famille bien évidemment
n'était pas un héros c'est un assassin
o'neill avait assassiné après fait je
rappelle d'ailleurs puisque sa petite
musique et parfois la presse nationale a
repris comme quoi il serait innocent et
eu trois procès est lé nouveau coup dur
pour valérie pécresse la candidate des
républicains en effet contracté locaux
vides 19 valérie pécresse qui annonce
qu'elle poursuit sa campagne à distance
l'ancien roi d'espagne juan carlos ne
sera pas protégée par la justice
britannique l'homme poursuivi pour
harcèlement envers son ex campagne son
ex-compagne avait réclamé d'immunité
personnel en tant que membre de la
famille royale la haute cour de londres
lui a refusé